hi guys
so today i'll be playing a kind of dlc
for to the moon if you haven't played to
the moon you need to
i'll put a link in the description below
or you can always look it up on youtube
there's loads of people that's on let's
plays
it's basically about two kind of
scientists that go back
in people's past and change their lives
to be how they want them to be just
before they die so
it's quite sweet and quite sad but it's
a very lovely game this is just
kind of a holiday special for you to get
more insight on the story
and yeah stuff like that
and rotten tomatoes i think
that's all very nice it's very rude
actually
is he setting a trap looks like
he is oh he's gonna
pour water all over
that backfire didn't it
wait there's no meeting today yeah and
i'm not dumb
see girls aren't um twice in one day
really
oh fair enough besides
that's actually dangerous what if it
hits my head without tipping over
but you still made it hit my head
that's different yours is pretty thick
well i saw what you want excuse me for
giving you a chance to
even the scores
but seriously drop by i actually do have
something to show you
just give me a few first she's not that
stupid
you're gonna go say hi to them at the
party downstairs
maybe later grab me a drink if you go
party oh this is my office
so if you didn't know they're kind of
like scientists
it's been a while since i played that
kind of what they call themselves
dear diary today i shoot i can't just
leave my
diary out like this better lock it away
before someone sees
good idea let's go in here
hey it's not ready yet okay
at least not putting another bucket of
water up there it's always good sir
so many doctors
oh look this one's oh it's a toilet
do you need to give it for a little
pedal
nice ringtone what
i just remembered because you also gave
me some cake for that drink
how did you know that'd be cake there's
always cake
there's always cake well pick one i'm
not your waitress
hey so which is it oh wait that was the
girl hey so what is it
oh neil
i'm thinking look i gotta go i'll call
you back
okay why did the music girl weird oh
oh hey eva roxy you all right
huh oh well we went outside to get
something from the car
and well you know
them again huh what are they talking
about
well it is that time of year
look don't tell the others okay
i don't want everyone to be all tensed
up about it
maybe it'll be clear by the time
everyone leaves
i hope so come on
let's go see what the others are up to
it's like inside stuff i don't know what
they're talking about okay
okay then
woohoo that's why it looks banging
i want some cake give me the cake
presents cake
presents old man
hey willis looks like logan's putting a
move on your girl over there
wait what
she ain't going anywhere oh i don't know
willis
logan does sing like an angel
i do yeah what is oh
yeah willis i heard he's an exquisite
dancer too
i am well i got
three strands of hair on my head and
each of them is willing to fight for him
in the parking lot
okay this is getting too weird for me
he's funny i'm not really sure what to
do here either
since we were full house today eddie was
allowed to drink but now he won't stop
talking
maybe he just needs someone to listen
yeah
that's what i fear the most oh poor guy
you know what bugs me lisa we can alter
memories
yet i can neither make my hair as
buoyant as logan's
nor as silky as yours yeah
it's a tragedy nice hat
my dear good afternoon timer
you know you never responded that email
i sent you about my nephew
i attached a photo of him and everything
oh no she tried to
get them to date uh thanks i'm just not
looking
oh it's that boy neil isn't it
what no i like to keep my
personal and professional life separate
wow
then that's just one more reason why my
nephew is perfect for you
you two are going to be so happy
together
oh dear hey eva
hey how did that last mission go i heard
you guys run into some complications
it was fine bureaucrat's bureaucracy
just got in the way
but i'm trying to forget about work now
there's enough about to go around later
simon and i are discussing our taste in
early
borough paintings
they're all good yes yes they are
okay i don't even know what they are but
i'm just gonna say yes yes they are
drink cake get some cake cake
cake no stand in front of the cake
fine don't stand up in the cake whatever
look i know it's hard not to think about
it but worrying doesn't fix
anything i know but
what was your last patient's wish huh
oh well she wished to see the world
and did she yeah we took her all over i
even caught glimpses of places that i
haven't been to
she was so happy it sounds like she
would have really appreciated what you
did for her
you've helped a lot of people roxy
i'm sure if they could speak to you
they'd all tell you
what's out there right now doesn't
change that
i guess so i do feel better thinking
about it
no i do feel better thinking of that
thanks eva
it's the holidays don't let it ruin the
mood
it's christmas
okay what do i do now right so he wants
like a drink
but i can't get to the cake
and i can't pick up any drink okay i'll
just go back up there
i love the music in these games it's so
cute
see there's scientists that can alter
people's past
just before they die if you didn't know
what those conversations were about
okay so that's that weird noise again
neil
it's weird what is he doing the line's
busy
oh dear this is not good
maybe he's in the toilet
it's the only other place i can think of
going it's the only place i can go
okay let's try the doors again
oh good try but there's no water bucket
this time
is everything okay you seem distracted
what yeah it's all good i'm fine
anyways i'm just about wrapping this up
i'll call you when it's done either
okay back to work
weird
where's neil in his office i don't
really know what he's up to
as per usual i see i don't know what to
do okay
oh god by the way thanks for coming my
devil call yesterday
i heard it went well not much
i haven't seen at this point
i don't think you could use a break
sometime
we've still got some kicks left in our
old bones
besides some patients prefer us having
practitioners with more life experience
just to be sure take care with you've
got your limits too
eva i have peace of mind knowing that
when the day comes our fate will be in
your hands
ah don't be so dark
that's not nice to talk about oh who's
this
who's this dude hello
don't go out by now eva i know
roxy told me there's persistent buggers
looks like they're there to stay oh yeah
okay he's ready yeah
it's ready either come over when you can
i'm coming i'm coming
shut the door uh why
because i'm supposed to be using this
computer for work remember
if rob saw he'd be all like slacking off
again neil
der
why didn't she close the door she just
left it open
what is that here have my seat
he doesn't even care that she didn't
actually close it or whatever
remember that oh yes
you need to play the game to remember
this is like a big part
of the first game to the moon
please tell me you folded it yourself
lighten up there are hundreds of them
besides it's not like lily and the kids
have any use for them anyhow
and what good is it to you jump starting
your memory for one
now launch that program i don't know if
i want to
oh come on i worked hard on it
ah this is awesome
cool okay
what ta-da
this is just plainly disrespectful
hey now video games are an art form they
passed the laws decades ago
yeah but this might make them revoke it
stick some stones either you haven't
even played it yet
go on try it come on eva i want to play
it
what is it so weird oh
okay what's this
what the bloody hell okay
this is so weird
oh oh no there's an evil zombie
yeah i know i saw it
looks familiar
oh look it's a little life
is that a cat no it's like a bag or
something
thank you whatever that is
oh no oh god i
suck all right i'm just gonna
i'm dead without the a
yay okay
i don't know what i'm doing i'm just
gonna go ah
yeah i rule
what is that grapes
oh dear evil grapes
okay oh no
don't do it so fast oh my god
i have one life left i wish i could save
i'm so scared
why did i do that i'm so stupid
yes
i'm so confused about where i should be
going here
oh yeah not that way oh my god
i'm gonna die no no no no i'll be okay
bunny
i used to make games like this when i
was your age
because i didn't close the door what the
how cute is that floating head character
you neil
how long have you guys been standing
there seems like you've been slacking
off again
man i told you he'd say that get out of
my office guys this is private space
see eva this is exactly what happens
when you leave the door open i did
i didn't tell him that the door still
just can't hear me
i might as well go stretch my legs just
realize you didn't get me a drink
or cake she's awful friend you can keep
on playing though
oh thank you i think i shall
okay
oh no okay i'm okay
okay
oh my gosh three are you kidding me
um
oh my god i don't know how i did that
how [ __ ] cool is that
okay i thought i might have to memorize
no
thank you for the platypus
what them don't do that to me
oh no
i'm not even moving it okay she's just
freaking out like i don't know
oh she died she gave up
hey eva did you oh
yeah she left she got bored
and then you all like feel my hair feel
it
man i'm never drinking more than a shot
of beer again
okay that's so weird
neil uh yes roxanne
are you looking for eva yeah how do you
know
i just saw her down the hall looking
upset wait
why is that assumed to be my fault
well when i look at your face i get the
feeling that you'd piss me off a lot if
you and my partner
not thanks but i mean that in the nicest
way
in what way could that possibly be nice
never mind
look thanks for the info i'll check
upstairs
so i think she's in the toilet i know
she's in the toilet
she must be in the toilet
oh look at this what is this
i haven't seen this before this is
different
oh look there she is
hey
you didn't finish the game
i've played enough of it
don't tell me you're upset about the
zombies
you made them yourself don't you
remember
and it was clearly a joke sheesh
i'd ask when you have become so uptight
but
you know come over here neil
oh dear are you gonna punch me
i've been practicing my kawakian child
you know i'm telling you my hands are
like lightening
even i can't contain my moves
it's a serious time
whoa
record show up huh
voxes said they've been gathering since
morning
that's quite some dedication for no pay
when i signed up for this job i thought
it'd be respectful
fulfilling dreams and all but those who
thank us are dead
and those who support us are the dying
you might not like how i do things but i
do them for this patient's sake
and more often than i'd like for yours
to save your sorry ass from getting
fired
yeah good job with that it's a feat
do you think they're right hmm
all those people out there they are all
standing for what they think is right
gee i sure hope not but hey
everybody has their beliefs
there are a lot of them but don't forget
that there are a lot of people with us
too remember lily
they aren't as outspoken because those
who are content rarely feel the need to
bother
but we have to remember that they're out
there and remember each patient we once
visited
visited remember how hard we tried
and how they left this well the smile in
the place of a frown
sometimes that fleeting moment of shared
happiness is all it takes to make it all
worthwhile
are you drunk now hey i'm just recycling
rob's bs here give me a break
but look if you're asking me whether
what we do matters
i guess it does for the brief fraction
of a second before they pass on
is that enough for you
sometimes i don't really know
how about you are you really happy doing
this
hey i'm just happy that we make a lot of
dough
i don't know about you but i'm totally
balling
at the grocery i'm all like heck yeah
i'll shell out five cents for a plastic
bag
here's a quarter that's how i roll
you know that game you made of it it
wasn't all terrible
i'm listening i mean
the graphics are antique and the game
plays a pushover but uh
i'm surprised you still remember all the
johnny and river stuff
yeah sorry about the zombies but hey you
shouldn't have
you should have really played it till
the end all the zombies rally together
and become the heroes to save the day
really totally and they're like
fire rags and pom-poms as all the
johnnies and rivers chant your name
hmm i guess i should go finish it then
whoa whoa let's not be hasty the game's
not going anywhere
you can finish it in a one no two weeks
hello
thanks for the discount but we're not
looking for premium snowplowing service
right now
you should encode your number that'll
block most of the telemarketers
just kidding we're actually being
drafted by a patient
in critical condition wait what
understood we'll be right over are you
serious yeah come on we can't afford to
be late
you can't just joke around about these
things
you're serious neil
so they're off to help another dying
patient fulfill their dreams
their life dreams
so i'm guessing all these people don't
like what they do
oh that was a lovely little
short dlc if you will honestly if you
haven't played to the moon you need to
play it or at least watch
it's got to be like the most emotional
game i've played
it's got a brilliant storyline the
concept behind it is just
amazing it's like how can someone come
up with these ideas i cannot wait for
the second one the second one's going to
be called a bad story
and it's going to come out sometime soon
he's still working on it
but that's why he made this little one
here just so we could have something to
play
and it was really nice it kind of helps
you understand a little bit more the
relationship between the characters
and it's really good so i put my voice
over everything i was
actually being a zombie last night so my
voice is kind of gone
have a lovely day or evening bye
oh my god let's see did you go
it's not as good as i thought
oh my god